welcome back to cloud storage bytes now
that you've got the billing basics let's
add a level of complexity like when a
client needs to be billed for their
usage of your resources today on cloud
storage bytes will take you into the
world of requestor pays
whenever a user accesses a cloud storage
resource like a bucket or an object
there are charges associated with both
making and executing the request this
includes operation charges for
performing a request Network charges for
reading the data and data retrieval
charges if the data is stored as
Nearline storage or cold line storage
now normally the project owner of the
resource is billed for these access
charges but this isn't always
appropriate
if the requester provides a billing
project with their request the
requesters project can be billed instead
and this feature is appropriately called
requester pays with requester pays
enabled on your bucket you can require
requesters to include a billing project
in their request
thus billing the requesters project
enabling requester pays is useful for
example if you have a lot of data that
you want to make available to your users
but you don't want to be charged for
their access of that data note that
there are some charges that are always
going to be applied to the project
containing the bucket even when
requester pays is enabled these charges
include storage charges for storing data
in a bucket and any applicable early
deletion charges for complete details on
those caveats go ahead and check out the
docs linked below
and now let's look into how to enable
requester pays start in the cloud
storage browser in the Google cloud
platform console in the list of buckets
find the bucket that you want to enable
and click the off button in the
requester pays column in the window that
appears click enable once enabled a
green bubble and on will appear in the
requester pays column for that bucket of
course once you enable requester pays
you may need to disable it so let's walk
through that process as well to disable
requester pays on a bucket go ahead and
start in the cloud storage browser in
the Google cloud platform console in the
list of buckets find the bucket you want
to disable and click the on button in
the requester pays column in the window
that appears click disable once disabled
a gray bubble and off will appear in
there
mr. paise column to check whether
requestor pays is enabled on a bucket
take a look at the list of buckets the
requester pays status of each bucket is
found in that requester pays column so
we've looked at how to enable and
disable requester pays on your own
storage buckets but what if you're on
the other side what if you're the
account who wants to access an object
stored in a requester pays bucket let's
checkout accessing requester pays
buckets using GS util here's how to
include a billing projects that you can
download an object store it in a
requester pays bucket project ID is the
ID of the project to be billed for
example my - project bucket name is the
name of the relevant bucket for example
my - bucket object name is the name of
the object you want to download for
example pets / dog object destination is
the location where you want to save your
object for example desktop / dog keep in
mind that buckets that have requester
pays disabled still accept requests that
include a billing project and charges
are applied to the building project
supplied in the request so make sure you
consider any billing implications prior
to including a billing project in any of
your requests there's more to come about
cloud storage but that's gonna be for
another episode if you want to know more
about using requester pays check out the
links in the description don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what you want to learn about Google
Cloud storage thanks for joining us for
this quick byte of cloud storage see you
next time
[Music]